this is a difficult one so if i change
your other
on one more five more
so you come in and here you're going to
use this arm down
this this arm here you're gonna
capture this arm all right it's really
hard to throw anybody
with that arm if you do it physically
do all sorts of things
what i'm trying to do is come here and
bring it over what i should be doing
is what richard was showing that is to
gel with my bed and make my body more
[Music]
this arm whatever you've got here you'll
try to trap
and see if you can do it by mounting
your body
rather than trying to get in there with
this armor this arm's gonna be difficult
i
could try and throw with this you've got
to do it
you'll notice that here's that tummy
again
going back same as it did earlier
so just look up what you can do with
moving more shapes rather than
what you can do by fizzing pounding each
other down